we flew him all the way from Grand
Rapids Michigan it is not close he's the
number six light heavyweight in the
world you might know him as sweet dreams
I know him as Jamal Hill on this week's
food truck Diaries and I'm feeding them
CJ's Wings let's go
[Music]
[Music]
what's up brother
you look big ass dude man yeah I like to
eat yes I guess so I didn't realize how
[ __ ] big you were makes sense I mean
all I feel like all the dudes and you
allude to this in your interviews like
it's a changing of guards that light
heavyweight like I mean you're a big ass
dude man you guys weren't this size when
I was finding that light heavyweight
look I look smaller on on camera you
really do I always thought you were
undersized yeah so that's what most
people think how's it going he could
probably fight middleweight not a chance
you might go to the heavyweight
eventually you know what I'm saying I
like gold man I like gold so well
hopefully they give you a chance to at
least attempt to get that gold because
your division's a little tied up with
the rematch right with yawn with uh with
your boy Yuri and Glover right so you
got to wait for that so you're kind of
like in this weird kind of gray area
just waiting for the next call yeah and
when you look at the I guess top six
really you're six in front of you got
Anthony Smith hurt he's hurt after him
you got is it racket he's hurt
so then you got Mega Mod right he you
know so yeah man but him the thing is
right yes probably they might match them
up together you know I I certainly take
take either one yeah but um
yeah bro it's it's a weird situation if
it's up to you what would you do if
you're the Matchmaker what do you do
with your mom here if it was up to me
I mean and I'm thinking like
futuristically and I'll give you a
little breakdown into my mind uh match
me me and yam blahovich up let me uh let
Margaret wait and uh fight the winner
Glover and
uh the number one Contender take the
take the winner I like that I like that
no uh I think I think because Margaret
is Young and at the top they're like a
little bit older except for of course
Yuri uh I'd rather fight him for a title
I think that's a nice pay-per-view
that's a dope pay-per-view and I also
think you're more well known especially
here in America with the fans so if you
launch Mega Mod right to the top it's
almost yeah he has the talent to do it I
just feels like star power I think they
got to focus on that a little more I
mean that could come that could come
with with that for sure becomes champ
yeah
if he gets the Bell if he gets the belt
from Yuri yeah I mean I think I think
that would that would do that yeah I'm
not mad at you just in a bit of a tough
situation then when you won your fight
against Santos which is a dope ass
knockout you win that fight and then you
got the mic in the post fight press
conference you you called out John and
then you got some backlash from the fans
right like some fans like he ain't ready
for you on I was like well hold up to
use your defense so that's like well Jan
lost to Santos right you just start
Santos what the [ __ ] are you all talking
about right little MMA little MMA half
but still that's how that's yeah but
yeah I mean not a well not only that
um look at what look at what Santos did
against the entire top the top five the
footage is there yeah you know from from
one from he's a Savage man yeah Santa's
a Savage um and look at the result from
there fighting like what happened in
there like what happened whenever
yeah so I mean I'm not a believer in MMA
math like oh you beat these guys up but
whenever you see how he was met how what
he did again yeah the only time I use
that memory math is for this it's like
well hold on you can't say he's not in
his League because he just starts a dude
who beat him right so that it's like my
math doesn't work when you say no this
guy's gonna win but to say that he's out
of your league doesn't make sense in any
facts right yeah that's when I use MMA
map when it works to mine the guys they
haven't seen an interview with uh with
James Lynch where uh
Beyond responded I think he said
something like he thinks I'm not ready I
need I need a little bit maybe a little
bit more time not not just yet maybe
because you don't want a piece of this
just yet come get these hands and find
out because they don't want a piece of
it yeah yeah it's definitely ready
it's cooked it's done yeah it's cooked
the pot is ready I had Laura senko and
we're talking about Dana White Contender
series like people that come out of
there and they're Superstars that come
out you're one of the dudes that came
out of there man for sure look at you
you know I mean I know I know a lot of
people don't know it ain't it ain't so
much but yeah definitely though that's
where I came from that's why I got my
first start yeah cause your name doesn't
get brought up with it because there's
like sugar Shawn right and you got Bo
Nichols doing the damn thing there's a
million other guys that came shout out
my boy Jeff Neal you know yeah yeah just
Neil yeah takes Roadhouse shot takes
Roadhouse that's where he used to work
um before and I think he was able to
quit that job after his last win or last
few thank God but uh yeah your name
doesn't get brought up a lot there just
because people forget because when I was
looking at yourself like right that we
came from Dana White Contender series
man that was your ticket to the
Chocolate Factory it was it was that's a
big moment for you um yeah that was that
was it I was like five fights into my uh
into my pro career I got the call I was
actually already had a fight book I was
about three about three weeks out for
that you know for a fight outside of the
UFC oh worse for a fight outside of uh
USS was supposed to fighting some guy
from Brazil and um I got the call like
right as I was getting in the car to go
to training yeah it was it was it was a
big moment it was it was it was what
I've been waiting for I always knew that
once once I got the opportunity one
soccer to be seen I just needed to be
seen because I've been putting the work
in I've been putting the work in for
years you know a lot of people may not I
may not have went about it like the
conventional route the loud route like a
lot of people did but I definitely put
the work in and I'm not sure I was where
I needed to be ready for the opportunity
exactly yep you know I mean so when it
came I was
happy that I had it when I made the most
of it yeah you definitely did because
only five fights in Dana White Contender
series and then where you're at now six
in the world pretty freaking nuts dude
I've had more fights in the UFC than I
have
outside yeah because usually especially
this day and age like especially if you
look at the light heavyweight division
like I mean you've by far have the least
experience but with you when you look at
the box and like you're boxing me a
problem for a lot of guys you've just
always gravitated towards boxing because
it's also before you answer it's not
like you come from this Mega camp like
these other boys like ATT AKA Jackson's
or high altitude like these huge camps
like you're doing the damn thing in
Grand Rapids yeah um well the whole the
boxing the boxing thing um I always had
hands yeah but um my strike and I say my
striking as a whole like elbows knees
kicks I do it all I do it all at a very
high level
um the thing with boxing is I realized
the the deficiency I didn't realize the
deficiency in the sport you know I mean
and honestly a lot of it was really was
it was Amplified to me with uh when
Connor fought Floyd
you know uh and you could see like he
was right at the top he was at the top
he's looking at like all these the butt
when it came down they're punching and I
seen it I had seen the first in the Diaz
fight you know the boxing the endurance
that he took to be a boxer there yeah I
seen how it translated over into boxing
so it's like all right how can I take
this deficiency and make it work for me
and MMA yep and then a lot of times guys
will do that like uh like a Diaz brother
where the the emphasize you know in in
boxing and a lot of it's the volume
because boxing a lot of its volume
punches and the the pressure but you
just happen to have this skill we got
some knockout power yeah it's uh it
comes with that I I've always been I've
been in a lot of fights so I I noticed
I've knew a long time ago usually when I
touch people they go to sleep really you
got what poor kid in fourth grade found
out that you have this god-given power
what poor fourth grader is like you
ain't gonna do [ __ ] yeah number six
ranked like heavyweight in the world I
actually knocked my best friend out when
I was a kid really you guys are like
messing around nah he like he he did
like he he liked he's got a very a very
crazy sense of humor so he did a joke
that I didn't think was funny he's too
funny I hate the prices
we might have been like four or five or
something like that but four year olds
knock each other up were your parents
like he might we went beyond to
something man it was it was funny my mom
my mom loves to tell this story just
because I like really the whole reaction
and everything well especially I'm gonna
have to say that one I'm gonna have to
say it I want to let my mom yeah we'll
get your mom out you should have told me
you're gonna flown your mom out tell
that epic story
and I'm sure your mama now is super
proud watching she watches everything or
because there's there's two different
type of parents some will watch and then
like with one Outlet I can't and then
some are like into it my mom my mom is
definitely into it she locked in she
don't want to see me get hurt and things
like that but you know she just she
don't she don't want to miss nothing yep
she want to miss that has she has she
been to one live yet yeah she was there
when I got uh when I fought on Contender
series oh dope like I said and also like
the UFC messed up in the edit before my
last one my mom's name is not Sandra
Floyd Hill I don't know my mom they
messed up your mom's name that's their
mom's name and she is upset about it
she's upset about it his name is Shiva
Tucker Oh that I mean I mean close
somebody's [ __ ] up
do you so does your is that the only one
your mom went to or she's been to others
she's been uh no she's been nervous and
she is she intense like rip his head off
she hasn't been she hasn't been the
other like UFC yeah she's like my mom
like my mom has like you know she has
Health we're health things and things
like that but she's been she's been to
other fights yeah for that dope man I
used to fight strictly used to fighting
Grand Rapids like we had a nice arena
there yeah there was a promotion that
was going to bring guys fight scene's
good in Grand Rapids it was I mean the
history of Grand Rapids you know Floyd
Mayweather comes out of there yeah Floyd
Mayweather Senior come that like there's
a hole who else is James Tony from there
there's a rich history of real Fighters
out of Grand Rapids so you're just kind
of carrying on that too it's the first
UFC one right yeah yeah as far as like
doing it to this level I'm sure there's
been others with that yeah like six in
the world
well not not exactly Grand Rapids but
it's like it's pretty much the same area
same area code uh Cody statement oh yeah
he's a stud yeah Cody statement came he
came uh he came from the same area like
I actually have a DVD where I think it
was
my second amateur fight back in like
2010 Cody was like the headline Cody on
a DVD oh that's cool you guys your boys
uh yeah we cool he's a stud he's stuck
we trained we trained together we
trained together a little bit back in
the dance that's cool
well you don't have a fight come up for
a while because the light heavyweight
division is pretty tied up I don't think
the title fight till December so you can
add a few pounds on we're about to get
sick man so let me feed you we fill you
all the way out here let me feed you and
we'll get back to it man let's do it
[Music]
how you doing
thanks for having us appreciate it
uh I'm gonna keep it simple go with one
of your classic here the the picture
sold me I'll go with the the chicken
wings with your hot sauce I think I'm
gonna go with the with the chicken
tenders the chicken tenders all right
chicken tenders with the boss sauce of
course I have to a mile can I get mild
though you got loud all right we'll keep
it real nice okay
sweet dreams yeah
um can I get some potato salad that
looks really good yeah it does look nice
it's really good all right guys it's
guys thank you so much
thank you
appreciate it
[Music]
let's take a little break from chatting
with my boy Jamal Hill because man it is
a scary time out there Halloween's
coming up you got Michael Myers got
Freddy Krueger costumes you got all
sorts of scary costumes but you know
what really scary that bush you're
rolling with in these costumes you're
around kids around your girl you got
these tights on you got this big bush
you're scaring everybody not for the
right reasons luckily my friends at
manscape launched the fourth generation
performance package to make sure your
pumpkins get the ultimate carving
experience on this spooky day
that's a metaphor for trimming around
your wiener all right turn your bite
size treat to a king-sized candy a lot
of Halloween references and join the six
million men worldwide who trust manscape
by going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with the coach shop 20
that's schaub20 make the right call this
spooky season it's trick or trim get it
have you ever tried to trim your balls
and turn into a Freddy Krueger film
it's not good guys well luckily manscape
is here to save the day and make sure
you don't look like Freddy Krueger below
the belt there all right unlock your
confidence down below with your wiener
all right with the performance package
4.0 inside you'll find the Holy Grail of
Men's Grooming items that made it easy
for you to upgrade your grooming routine
I gave my bush the Philly fade the other
day and I put all sorts of designs in it
all right it's a full moon out and the
Werewolf in your pants is howling again
a Halloween reference for you guys it's
time to tackle that problem with the
lawnmower 4.0 all right we got you
covered man the performance package 4.0
also includes the weed whacker a total
game changer for your men's hygiene
Arsenal the weed whackers The Nose End
air uh hair trimmer if you have hair
come on your nose and ears what are you
doing you don't probably don't need a
Halloween mask you're scaring everybody
as well all the girls you're probably
single so don't do that and use this to
get a girl all right seal the deal with
manscape's liquid formulations their
crop preserver bald deodorant and crop
reviver ball toner will make sure your
Halloween reference pumpkins stay fresh
manscaped also just launched a new body
buffer the 100
antibacterial body scrubber it's just
what you need to keep your fresh and
clean this Halloween when you take that
costume off you're all sweaty use this
body buffer to get your brain right
right manscape even threw in two free
gifts of their performance package 4.0
the manscape boxers which I love and the
shed travel bag you put all that stuff
in there you're ready to go man also if
you're looking like Wolverine haven't
cut your nails recently be sure to look
into the sheer 2.0 nail kit I could use
those but for my toenails my toenails
are like a Velociraptors and when I was
a kid I used to be able to put my toe in
my mouth but I'm getting older and I'm
not as flexible my youngest son can do
it I'm proud of them but I can't do that
so I need to share 2.0 nail kit uh get
20 they're thick too dude they you hear
them snap when I cut these things all
right get 20 off and free shipping on
the code shop20 atmanscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with a coach
shop20 at manscape.com say Trick or
Treat to your beautiful new Halloweeny
with manscaped happy Halloween
this episode of food truck dies my boy
Jamal Hills also brought to you by the
best Kratom on the planet the only
Kratom I trust on this planet I don't
want Mars I don't know about Uranus but
how about Earth if I want Kratom I'm
using happy hippo I'm shooting the pink
lemonade shot before I hit the stage if
I do a podcast I'm using it all they got
gummies pills whatever you need powders
we got it all baby it's the best focused
product I've ever used best of all it's
all natural all right so visit
happyhippo.com use promo code thick boy
you get 20 off for Life use that code as
many times as you want share it with
your aunt Uncle your cousins your
nephews your stepdad stepmoms even right
they can be difficult but share the code
with them that's happyhippo.com use
promo code thick boy for 20 off for life
for the best Kratom on the planet happy
hippo all right my man food is here I I
messed up not going with the uh potato
salad
yeah it usually looks way by mine that's
cool that's not a big deal that's fine
here's a fork if you want a little knife
I don't know how you use tenders do you
go knife and fork on tenders you guys
real proper out there in Grand Rapids no
we get in there we go yeah you get your
hands wet man yeah you never I don't
want to assume but I assume you guys do
yeah and you went with medium huh not a
Spice Guy
no not too much of a cake don't can't be
kicking me too much
not hot it's [ __ ] hot
that's hilarious holy [ __ ] yeah no it's
good it's good oh man uh it's nice man
yeah man I'll tell you what man they
weren't lying this some kids use this
boss sauce instead of ketchup where
they're from she's at
um but you uh you grew up
in in general though as far as your diet
goes you have pretty strict diet you
have nutritionist everything like how
hard like what do you weigh right now
man like right now what do you think
we're all friends there nobody's
listening
yes I say around
235. yeah I'll tell you about 2 30 2 40.
right two more already we're not going
to leans
if you've been at 250 here man but when
you're to cut down to 16. I'm probably
60 yeah that's probably 60 for sure yeah
yeah I mean our Brand's thick but I
can't get too thin I [ __ ] up the
business you know but uh for you you
hire nutritionist is it hard for you to
get down to 205 no like for me I um I've
been doing this for for a while now so I
kind of know really yeah so I stick to
like kind of like the things and you do
it all yourself you're not you don't
have some big team cooking your meals
and no no damn look at you doing the
damn thing
most guys get fancy we didn't have you
know nutritionists and omniotics
yeah and stuff like that but uh but
you're good I got a pretty good idea of
what uh What uh like I know like certain
things like from certain menus that I
can eat you know that uh won't put too
much weight on me and things like that
but like oh yeah once the fight is over
um it's long gone away I go a little
petty what's your first goat like when
you when you starch though Santa or
Santos what was your Thiago Santos what
was your first meal
you have like a go-to celebration meal
was it pizza pizza's always easy well
especially here's the same way because
like you know you China you're trying to
you know you just won you know I was
sore I was trying to get some liquor in
me here's the thing listen it's a stupid
question because here's the thing when
you get done with those fights and you
go to the press conference you get back
to hotel what maybe 1 a.m midnight it's
late there's not a ton of options so
yeah Pizza you're not getting your you
know home-cooked meal whatever your
go-to is it's either like [ __ ]
nachos from the hotel or pizza or
something like that
would you like to get your drink up
I like that I like you know I had to go
out relax yeah
your Club guy you go to the clubs yeah
the woods in a club we have like a table
oh damn all right take it in all right
that sounds fun though it was fun you
deserve it man so growing up though
you're one of the guys you start finding
that you start fighting at 18 which to
be honest is I mean that's pretty early
for Guys these days I mean some guys
like I've been doing Taekwondo since I
was seven doesn't count doesn't count it
doesn't [ __ ] count nobody's competing
Taekwondo the real athletes are in
Taekwondo you know what I'm saying so
you grew up uh basketball football you
must have been pretty damn good at
basketball because on your Wikipedia it
says you had an offer to play even
college ball a little bit huh yeah I was
going I was gonna go play at Davenport
University it's like a local College
still to play college ball at basketball
you're going to be pretty damn good
there's a lot of basketball players out
there you know I worked hard you know it
was like so like
just like I work hard now with MMA back
then that was my thing so I used to work
hard like
whenever I visualize something and I'm
passionate about something
like I go all I go in I go all in on it
you know it's like it's like an
obsession yeah
like my mind like my mind gets fixated
on it and it's like it's like it's like
I'm crazy you become obsessed with it I
like sitting there sitting in there you
probably gonna have it there sitting
there sitting there and late at night
middle of the night you just you
thinking and you're feeling you actually
feel those moments and things like that
so I used to do the same thing with
basketball then like I get up so I'm
waiting waiting for the sun to come up
so then I go I get the sun comes up and
then I go and I um I play basketball go
down to the court of Court not that far
from my house yeah even in the winter
I've gone in the winter with a shovel
went and Shove It Off the course the
hoop just the hoop but I think that's
when you know you're doing the right
thing when you're like passion out
obsessed with it and you're not like
it's not like a drag like you know I
mean some days don't care about listen
I'm sure you love the fight but there's
some days during camber like God dog I'm
exhausted you know when you just
sometimes the Cam's tougher than the
fight you're like [ __ ] man I'm sorry to
get this over with but you know with
your passion for basketball so at 18 you
just decide to walk into a gym and start
boxing
so
um my scholarship wasn't a full
scholarship and I was like partial
so it was like all right well I'm
looking at numbers I'm like all right
you're going to incur this much today
you have to make up this you might have
a good job to do this all right but and
now even up up to this point now I feel
like if I was actually really to put my
talents on display like that to be
noticed and I was in that position I
wouldn't even be at this school yeah you
know what I'm saying so it's like so
it's like all right what if this don't
happen and that's like a real deal like
that's like a real deal like you know
I'm a real rich in person yeah or
something I really thought about and
it's like what am I going to study
what's my other thing I was like I don't
know
so I mean Curt that and then if this
don't turn out I don't know what I'm
gonna do yep
um it from like that's not it that's not
it I'm
to me that's dumb yeah you know what I'm
saying and I'm not I don't I don't do
things like that so not smart I think
more young kids will realize that too
let's go to college get all this debt
and then I major in communication
because I just take a year off like I
was like [ __ ] I don't like going to
school like that yeah so I take it
you're out and figure out each other
yeah so you took a year off and then
where the hell does fighting but did you
always want to fight MMA bro I always
got into fights bro I've been fighting
my entire life like I'm talking like
one-on-ones 104s 108 1012. one on 12.
what do you find in Russia Jesus Christ
I fought tall people love myself before
like just situations [ __ ] happens you
know what I mean and man you know next
thing you know you you're just fighting
you know I mean I'm just reacting and so
it was anybody like damn it mom's pretty
good at fighting oh yeah yeah your mom
in fourth grade when you knock that's
kind of hard it's kind of harder tonight
you know I mean we get into a fight and
all of a sudden it's a bunch of people
sleeping yeah knocked down you're good
yeah your heart rate's not up yeah
yeah I bet yeah you're in the game sweet
dreams
hey fam let's take another little break
while I was eating food with Jamal Hill
I ran and changed my shirt just for you
guys I'm not doing this a different day
don't think that okay because UFC 280 is
here this Saturday the best card of the
year and you're gonna watch it can be
watching it on the live thick boy
YouTube you're watching the new fight
campaign the Salt Lake City fight
companion with Jesse on fire Frank mayor
myself you're watching like man I wish I
could watch you make bang bro well cool
now you can with my friends at freaking
DraftKings the official Sports building
partner of the UFC and right now new
customers can bet five dollars on UFC 80
and get 200 in free bets if your fighter
wins if you haven't tried draftking
Sportsbook
today's the day want even more action
say less you can also double your
winnings on the same game parlay combine
multiple Bets with like which fighter
will win how long the fight will last
and so much more listen kids you could
just you can bet on the freaking
favorite Muk Chev all day long if you're
gonna do it parl it mock Jeff wins and
it goes all goes the distance you can
parlay that
if you want to make a lot of money
though an actual you know have some skin
in the game I like taking Charles
Oliveira as the dog and then parlay it
with him gonna finish under five rounds
that's what I like but I like money so
it's also a dicey bet you never know all
right everyone who wants to boost their
winnings place a UFC 280 same game
parlay today download the draftking
Sportsbook app now use promo code shop
show throw down five dollars on UFC 280
and get 200 in free bets if your fighter
wins that's code Shob show a CH a b show
this Saturday at draftking Sportsbook
the official sports betting partner of
the UFC the main card starts at 11AM
Pacific Time holler at your boy fight
companion thick boy YouTube minimum age
and eligibility restrictions by C show
notes for details DraftKings
I'll tell you what lately on planes
usually like to read a book now I've
been listening to other podcasts I
listen to some music maybe it really I'm
listening other podcasts and it's been
great because if you notice my ears man
they don't fit your traditional uh in
wireless earbuds they just don't my my
left ear because of cauliflower looks
like a tortellini so I can't really
focus and the the the things just fall
out it's a disaster so while I'm on my
way to Salt Lake City this Thursday
Friday Saturday on the oh he said tour
you think uh what's he gonna do you
can't even listen to anything you're
wrong because raycon you got that
Brandon raycon wireless earbuds came
along and it it's the perfect fit for my
air why you ask hilarious because it has
the optimized gel tips it's the perfect
in-air fit so it looks it feels it
sounds better than ever and here's the
thing they will not budge trust me I do
it on bike rides while I'm working out
on the airplane to and from the hotel I
use them non-stop raycons I reached out
to them because I'm such a fan of their
product right Recons give you eight
hours of play time in a 32 hour battery
life raycons are also priced just right
you get quality audio at half the price
of other premium audio Brands it's no
wonder raycons every day earbuds have
over 50 000 five-star reviews all right
they can do it all you have three
customized uh sound profiles earbud tap
functions the noise isolation which I
love on planes and in my hotel awareness
mode so you got to know what's going on
you're hit by a car on your bike all
right go to buy raycon.com shop today to
get 15 off your raycon order that's by
raycon
b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n.com shop to score 15
off buy recon.com now let's get back to
the program
so you just started starting dudes
growing up and then you're just like ah
you watch the UFC fight or what what got
you down the UFC path because there's
always like a fight or maybe it's all
through a fight or something got people
hooked on it so I was at B-Dubs and I
actually saw the Anderson civil fight
right you had a place called beat ups
Buffalo Wild Wings oh word I forgot ah
damn I'd be for a kid yeah I don't know
no no no no no no no that's like nah so
I I keep forgetting that like over here
y'all have a different slang in time
yeah because I said I actually I asked a
lady for some pop over here and she
looked at me like I was crazy well in in
Denver we called soda pop too so you're
not wrong on that but also maybe you
don't use that term [ __ ] but also give
me a [ __ ] pop right like you know
what I'm saying it's not like you asked
for a Glizzy when we're talking about
you know it's like come on lady give me
a goddamn soda whatever the funky caught
give me the diet coke give me the DC
lady so you're at Buffalo Wild Wings in
salt Anderson Silva Anderson Silva
versus Forrest Griffin you saw Anderson
like I bet I could do that I starched
dudes it was no I was just like it was I
was I was amazed you know what I mean it
was like he's a freak something for
something like like it was I mean well
that was like one of the most
eye-catching nuts performances like I
think of all time I agree you know um so
I was like damn so those people out here
just really like that what if I run into
that guy yeah
what if I run into that guy so I need to
become that guy yeah you know and uh
that kind of sparked the interest and
then
um like I gotta I had to like growing up
you know like my like my group The Core
group of guys that I was around we're
brothers you know what I mean so it's
like like my God Brothers you know
um one of them actually did MMA he came
over to my brother's house and he showed
us his fight like on YouTube I'm like
I'm thinking like this is [ __ ] dope
yeah you know what I'm saying like he
actually has a fight exit went in there
and did it I was like I want to get in
there and do it I want to do it like the
other dude yeah you know what I'm saying
so uh so if you give you advice like go
to this gym do this because you told me
about that Jim yeah there's no there's
no like blueprint you know it's kind of
something like that go to that gym and
see what they say and then start
competing then you're in you know next
you know you're [ __ ] number six in
the [ __ ] world yeah in all facts
there's no blue percent yeah so you just
so that your buddy told you to go to
that gym you just walked in and then it
was on yeah oh no you know he did he was
actually at another gym he um he told me
to go to that gym and um like I talked
to him about it then another guy brother
their mind he has seen
a sign I said the first 30 days three
you free first 30 days a trial yeah like
a trial you gotta think like I mean I
ain't have money you know what I mean
like like well what are you 18 you have
money but like you know I mean but like
I have money like that you know what I'm
saying uh so
yeah I was 18 at the time so I I went I
went into the gym and uh never left
that's where I met my head coach now to
this day yeah holy [ __ ] that's your head
coach all my coaches
at that gym damn yeah you're a humble
ass dude most guys get big and like see
and they go these Mega Jammers you know
and you're just doing the damn thing no
man still have the same group of friends
I assume you still have the same group
of friends I mean yeah yeah that kid in
fourth grade he knocked out still cool
he's your best friend back then that's
fine he's still family
his pets were talking about it he laughs
about it all the time yeah like like him
like he was my like he he was my best
friend all through my childhood that's
cool man you know I mean then I moved to
Michigan you know even still through
that separation like kind of lost he
ended up he ended up eventually got
older he came to me she's been to
Michigan that's cool oh dope man there
you know I've been back humping back
down there and things like that I'm sure
he's super proud of you now yeah 100 I'm
sure you're super proud and then was
there a moment in career where you knew
your shout out Andrew Andrew August
what's his name Andrew Ogden Andrew what
Andrew Andrew
Ogden what up dude
um sorry about that concussion sorry to
hit you back
but uh was there is there a moment in
your fighting career where you're like
oh I I can take this pretty far like I
do I'm going to the UFC
um because everyone's doing me wrong
you're like I play Big Time college
football everyone in that room thought
they're going the NFL the odds are maybe
one and we're a big school the odds are
one percent are going down NFL 13 of our
senior class did we're outliers not a
big deal but in general one percent does
so in the UFC like think about all the
fighters that start to compete on your
local circuit maybe one of you are going
to make it you know what I'm saying so
the odds aren't great but they're but
it's the guys that believe in themselves
and then they have the skill so was
there a certain point early on your
career like I can do this did a did a
UFC like veteran come into your gym you
whooped his ass you're like if he if
he's had success I can definitely do
this or was there a moment we just start
some dude you know all right well like
it's like certain things happen in like
like I mean like
I don't like chapters almost right yep
so
um
from the gate I recognize things so I
recognize that I was and just
self-belief
um
I recognize I was that I was good ran
out the gate so right when you walked in
the gym yeah when I came in I was
sparring I was the guy inspiring like um
my main train Department my main spine
partner he's one of them he was uh he
was like one of the instructors when I
went to his name was Jorge Sarat
um he had fought Ben lackley uh like
some of us do I don't know if you're a
bad news being like yeah Hermes Veronica
yeah yeah old school by this dude on a
daily basis you know but at the same
time I'll notice all right this weapon
this weapon works all right some success
yeah some and then after that I always
like I always had the mindset all right
this works so I build off this add to
this so I was always so every day so
every time we're going I'm always adding
I'm always I'm always getting better I'm
always getting sharp you know to a point
where it started to get started to
realize the factory is a little bit
harder for him to get to me than
Instagram and just things like that yeah
and then we actually started our time we
actually just started going at it yep
you know
like almost like almost immediately yeah
almost immediately um which is rare yeah
even another guy oh there's another
um his name is Caleb Grumman um he's
actually heard he's got a fight because
he's fighting again soon with shout out
Caleb
um he was fighting on like he was like
boxing he was doing a pro boxing he's
fought on the undercar for Floyd and
things like that I sparked with him one
day he actually like first time me and
him sparred like I was catching him he
actually got upset and actually like
tried to come after me but
yeah
it is what it is I mean yeah I mean I
did I mean yeah you know what I'm saying
and then um
you know so that let me know too you
know um just no matter who I sparred
with like you know man obviously you
still have that nervous system
yeah but
I always have success yeah I mean like I
never I've never I've never just beat up
just got molly what I'm not inspiring
not in a fight like nothing I've never
just been just had my ass handed to me
like grappling yeah grappling has
happened obviously I was going through
going through that you know I mean how
how much do you because
this two-part question is a how much do
you focus on grappling B one of the good
things about this new age of light
heavyweights a lot of Strikers everyone
fasting himself a striker which I think
plays into your hand to get to that UFC
gold but you have John who will wrestle
grapple some obviously Glover's there
but you know he probably has one fight
left and then
magamad's kind of well I said that well
I say that well the grappling as opposed
to like coming in yes so like coming in
that wasn't my strong suit I'm like well
I'm saying you're a strong suit now like
what what where you're an outlier in the
top six is your boxing right like your
right hand you're one two like filthy
nobody else has that none of those guys
have that they just don't it's just you
worked hard it's not so god-given Talent
so that's where you're you're you're
different than those other guys if you
look at those other guy Five Guys ahead
of you they can't box like you can no so
that's your advantage yeah so my
question be if I'm them I also I also
think my advantage and the thing that
makes more dangerous than anything is my
IQ my awareness understanding what to do
in what moment and understand what's
what's happening and what my options are
correct and then that's also what I
think makes John the must ever do it I
think I don't if it was he the fastest
no it was the strongest no you you know
but he did everything pretty damn well
but his IQ same with GSP they were just
knew when to do it what's up Leon
Edwards as well yeah that's why that's
why um that's why I like that like when
it happened like I said that I said it
before the before the bike like the the
things about he knows exactly what
they're doing when they do it and he's
good everywhere yes you know what I'm
saying so that's like I mean that's to
me that's what everybody should try to
strive for yeah you know what I mean
just be be confident everywhere be at
the best you can everywhere be at a high
level everywhere and know when you need
to pull what out because guys have tried
you know uh Santos tried uh taking you
down like a lot of guys try to arrest
you because obviously they don't want to
stay on the feet because that's your
Advantage I'd assume that hasn't it
worked
that's my question for you how much do
you focus on wrestling and grappling
obviously a lot because they can't get
you down I grapple more than more than I
strike
you know when that gym that I walked
into it was a Jiu-Jitsu school yeah I
mean that's my uh my like you know my
black lion is black lion Jiu Jitsu
Academy yep at your school yeah I got
hands yeah the fight starts standing so
that's right I mean that's where I
wanted to get good at but it goes I'm
not worried I'm not I don't I don't feel
like a mess I don't look at myself
behind anybody in that regard
you know yeah I mean especially when you
look at the top the guys you know who
ranked ahead of you it's not I mean
Glover's the only one but again I I
think you and Glover are two ships in
the night you I don't think you guys are
ever gonna fight I think he does this
one probably loses and he's out you know
he's an older dude but as far as
grappling goes you know he's upper
echelon you're tough tough black belt
you know wrestling can box but you're
not gonna see that guy also but also I
would like to
um he's Legend oh yeah oh yeah I do I
don't think you well though um yeah yeah
and it's one of the unfortunate things
but I feel just because I I feel that
even even though okay he's he's more
decorated of a Grappler than me and
things like that but I feel I truly feel
my timing and my ability to know what to
do and how to control and capitalize on
it is is is that good it doesn't matter
yep you know yeah um like people say
whatever they want to say as far as like
the Paul Craig fight like you know but I
know the mistake I made in that fight
yeah and I know and I know where to
correct it can I can I outgrapple I mean
obviously yeah you obviously good
corrected it but I needed to do it it
needed to be things needed to be done on
my terms but also that Paul Craig glass
you want that to happen then so he could
focus on it because when you get to
where you're going now that's not gonna
happen again it's like it happening it's
Mega Med or any of these other dudes
yerry yawn that's not gonna happen you
want that to happen though yeah so you
could folk you need those small bumps so
you can focus on when you do get to that
you know title run which you're on now
that mistake doesn't happen you need
that [ __ ] yeah because you wouldn't want
that have to happen in the title fight
it's a nightmare you know what I'm
saying and when you look at the champ
when you look at like yerry uh do you
see holes in his game
yeah I definitely see I definitely see
um I see openings you know um I'm not
gonna say hoes it's actually
unconventional because you know I mean
because everybody fights differently
right yes so it holds me some I see I
see openings you know um when I see
things that I can take I see things that
I can take advantage of you know um I
see the type of fighter he is he's a
flow fighter yep you know um he gets he
gets the Rhythm he wants to get you in
that fight and get there and he wants to
control the chaos and flow through the
chaos and find his shot and find it he
likes what I want to do yeah that's what
I want to do I'm very good at that yeah
a lot of fun doing that yep you know so
that's why that's a fight that I want
let's find out yeah that's why I brought
up that's the fight I want yeah
like bad yep yep I would love to see
that fight yeah fun ass fight uh I will
end on this how do you think now that
John who's the king of the like
heavyweight division no he's gone yeah
DC gone gustin's out of there the only
guy's still doing it really is John
she's going to heavyweight how do you
think John does that heavyweight I think
John's John's a legend so I think he um
and I think he's his his gifts and
fighting translate uh Ascend Beyond
weight class I agree so um I think he'll
be fine well does that mean that he
won't have some adversity or some things
won't happen that might not that might
be cash probably won't yeah I agree
heavily yeah when he goes down he goes
bad yeah I mean so yeah but yeah I think
I think he'll be fine I actually wanted
me to do well because here's the thing
I'm gonna keep doing my thing and once
that once and once them challenge I'll
start knocking down certain challenges
you know those new challenges present
himself I'm hoping he's one of those I
have no problem following him up there
yeah that's great you know I mean
especially for something to be on that
type of level and that type of magnitude
I mean especially I do my thing here
hell yeah maybe go downstairs highlight
just yeah play around this away class
play around with some gold you agree
yeah I think that's the new wave of the
UFC too these guys to get that Superstar
level it's like the the Bounce Around
weight class kind of the new Vibe that's
what these guys are doing to become
Superstars the guy who I think is
eventually going to light heavy would be
Palms out I see him jumping up like
happy weight yeah
yeah he's Savage well dude we've watched
you on the show for a while but you keep
knocking dudes out and then you're
flying back home so finally we got you
here all the way from Grand Rapids keep
knocking him out dude we're rooting for
you here man I can't wait for your next
fight hopefully it's not super too late
but before you go we can't bring out
here not give you shoes man you know a
food truck dog so I know originally
you're from Chicago is there so born and
raised in Chicago you moved watches
Grand Rapids when you're 12. yeah yeah
so I got to get you the legend shoes
because you're a legend right so these
these are some Jordan threes now what
makes and you wear size 15's biggest
shoe we've ever seen
I actually stole these from
um Kevin Durant but no uh the size 15
were hard to find but uh the Jordan 3s
these are the first Jordans that Tinker
who's the legendary designer for Jordan
he's the first shoe he designed and when
Jordan wore these These are when uh he
had his biggest year ever and I think
you're about to have your biggest year
ever I bet you're about to do some [ __ ]
so Jordan had these for his biggest year
ever you're talking MVP uh defense
player of the year won the dunk contest
against uh Dominic Wilkins like he had
his biggest year ever and so that's why
I chose these for you these threes
because I think you're about to have a
big ass here my man so these are your
threes I appreciate it not easy to find
in 15. I'm trying to tell you bro I'll
tell you what I must be true
things coming on come on everybody
[Music]
foreign
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding
[Music]
back to my champion
we invented the era John Lennox
tanking out everybody one by one now the
challenges will come but you better
believe that man's gonna be ready for
them
[Music]
and everybody knows it
John Whitaker touches you he hurts you
Coming For You John chicken don't hide